joining us now with more fox news
contributor uh
dan bongino and and he has been very
public about he's a small investor
you know you got in very early i'm
jealous you were smart but more
importantly
i want everybody on twitter dan now
anytime they tweet
i want them to hashtag and open up their
parlor account as quickly as they can
and also tell remind people i'm moving
to twitter i'm moving from twitter to
parlor i'm moving a parlor or moving a
parlor
i have a parlor account but i'll let you
take it from here
yeah i i stopped posting on twitter last
night i'm not closing my account
but i won't be posting there anymore
ironically this all happens today sean
these big tech uh the big tech big
government symbiote because that's what
it is
um is now in an open war with free
speech and civil liberties in america
uh listen i'm not making a first
amendment argument for you here these
are private companies
i'm making an even more dangerous
argument that these tech companies are
more powerful than the government
and will have a more pernicious effect
on civil liberties
by engaging in open war with free speech
like they're doing right now
i can back that up right now at least
with government
you have a process if you're arrested by
the government or fined by the
government
there's a process that's you know the
law and order that's the order component
you can get a lawyer and you can fight
back that's not what you have
we have been threatened by apple with 24
hours notice
with nearly no legitimate recourse
whatsoever parlor
that we're going to be taken down from
their site by a monopoly company that
monopolistically controls its app store
even worse twitter bans the president
united states
while china is still posting about
sterilizing uyghurs
and the iranians are running their death
to america account
and so the liberals laughing about this
one more point i want to make on this
because there are many go to any social
media platform and you'll see it to the
liberals who think this is funny
remember famous last words in
unprincipled revolutions
not bedrocked in real principles and
there are no principles here other than
political ones
they're coming for you next famous last
words in the french revolution were
no no i was on your side there is no
side
this is a political attack this isn't a
principled one and they're coming for
you next
this fight's coming to your door folks
get ready you can't avoid it
uh well not not letting the american
people make up their own minds
uh if there's anything we could do to
help you i support
your efforts here and all your your
business partners for freedom of speech
not
speech you even necessarily at times
agree with
that's which is very clear um and i hope
people go to parlor.com
and i hope every time you're on twitter
say i'll move into parlor here's my
parlor address parlor
use twitter to promote parlor that's
what i say
because this is this is just that's
right unbelievable to me
um that this could happen dan bongino
thank you
all right